loop's are extremely powerful for
repeating the same set of commands over
and over but with different values a
for-loop starts with the word for and an
equation that defines the loop variable
the thing that is going to change its
initial value each time we go through
the loop in this case the loop variable
is IX the values that the loop variable
will take in this case are 1 3 and 2 the
loop variable will take on a different
value each time we go to the loop in
this case there are three values in the
array so we will execute the loop three
times the first time we will go through
the loop IX will have the value 1
because it's the first value in the
array in the loop declaration the first
time you go through the loop the for
statement is equivalent to typing IX
equals 1 the loop now execute every
command until it gets to the word end in
this case the only command is to say the
value of the number 1 the code now
returns to the for loop declaration now
we are going through the loop a second
time in this case IX will be 3 because 3
is a second value in the array in our
loop declaration now the loop does its
thing this process continues for each
value in the loop declaration array then
we're done with the loop MATLAB
continues with the code after the end
statement
you